k opponent is called before from
Argentina the Dutch defends okay it's
going for the stone wall normally this
is not such a great idea was this the
set up our wide let's see how it works
out
the stone was much less effective if
white hasn't fianchetto the bishop
strange not sure what this ideas which
lie to before we'll just make some
normal moves
yeah I just take a guess okay yeah I
guess I'd destroy the pawn structure
can't be bad for white what now if i go
for the simple queen bee three hmm if i
just go khatm ok let's try to fix the
pawns and the white squares a lot of a
lot of strange moves Bishop these three
perhaps 94 I can just take on d500 just
overly retreat now yeah it's just going
back of course you can play g5 now but I
don't really believe in this
let's see what they will do against
piling up on the C file this move just
wants to win some sort of tempo on b7
and then you can go for Roxy to with
Roxy one
yeah I just continue with the plan well
nitey for now this is just a big hole on
b6
not sure what will he play now let's see
8 then rook see one
what didn't I think a little bit longer
Knight b6 was also completely crushing
of course this is also good for white
but it's much less clear
ah this was really stupid stupid hmm
what do I do now I just I just needed to
to play Knight b6 and it's basically
over this isn't so clear at all
yeah this looks a bit threatening but it
doesn't really have anything here and I
get to play this move to kick the night
out again
yeah this is still fine for white I
think yeah this piece doesn't have many
squares yeah I need to do this now what
maybe I need to kick this night out with
f3 I maybe complain I'd see fire but
i can i can sacrifice exchange that I
think with a good position yeah 95 I
could take with the blonde Queen takes
in 94 and it's a good position again
okay this one
okay the night is ridiculous on a three
but I don't see how I can make any
progress while it's still in there
covering III
yeah like it's still fairly solid time
warning
black4 fits on fine yeah fortunately for
me he was getting really slow of course
and this one was okay just just
ridiculous I need to play Knight b6 of
course not be six then he might exchange
there and then rook c1 and it's just
it's just better for white for ages and
ages okay black is still fairly solid
it's it's looking a bit odd with the
bone structure but it's not not easy to
use so what I need to do this is just
bad to to allow him to to get this
activity would be fine if I day forward
he can take with the night now okay